tous les pays musulmans confronté à
l'intégrisme multiplient les appels à
l'aide aux pays occidentaux une aide
politique mais aussi économique et par
exemple venu chercher à paris le premier
ministre du pakistan benazir butto elle
a été reçue à l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui gilles rabin l'islam oblige
benazir bhutto ne peux pas serrer la
main des hommes en public bien qu'elle
soit premier ministre du pakistan est en
voyage officiel à paris bien sûr le
ministre de la culture jacques toubon
qui l'accueille au nom du gouvernement
le sait les ambassadeurs et les généraux
ont été prévenus mais pas et
photographes et cela m'oblige devant les
caméras benazir bhutto remis en place
son voile devant les députés de la
commission des affaires étrangères
actualité oblige benazir bhutto ne se
trompera pas de sujet elle parlera de
l'islam
le message du prophète est le même pour
tous dira-t-elle qu'on soit homme ou
femme c'est un message de tolérance de
justice et de modération nous et le
monde qu'ils soient musulmans ou non
musulman devons pas permettre que les
voix stridente de quelques extrémistes
des formes pour leur route politique
personnelle la vraie voix et l'expo du
message de dieu après avoir rappelé que
sur ce sujet les démocraties doivent
toujours rester en éveil
benazir bhutto se tourner vers valéry
giscard d'estaing la dernière fois je
vous ai vu lui dit-elle vous étiez
président vous aviez tenté de sauver mon
père emprisonné et promis à la mort mon
père a été exécuté
j'avais 24 25 ans je n'ai pas oublié